what's this it's scooby-doo's boner for
giant art fans the film is likely to
come come across as an orgy of yucks
for the rest it's the perche of yuck
this could compare to at least half a
dozen things that I've sadly been a part
of hmm is it Jay and Silent Bob I read
that script to see and I love clerks and
I was really admirer of him but when I
read it I said there's no way that
Lucasfilm will want me to do this
there's 15 f-bombs on every page don't
[ __ ] with the Jedi Master son and plus
I'm playing I tell young ones I said I
misread it I thought it said clock
knocker and he's using not a lightsaber
a bong saber so I thought I was being
very clever I said to Kevin well you
know I have to get this cleared at
Lucasfilm
but if they clear it you know I'm in
thinking that they're gonna don't get to
page three and go are you kidding me
Lucasfilm got to back to them and Kevin
called he's the only thing they were
concerned about is they wanted to make
sure that blew bong sabers are good and
read bong sabers are evil I said if that
doesn't indicate what a giant bunch of
nerds there are running that company and
I say that as a fellow nerd myself but
what's they they had no objection to
anything else
dark Falls Wow
I mean I don't even tell you this stuff
that they left on the cutting room floor
I mean scooby-doo hard on jokes really
they made a prop penis for that I said
what's this and the prop Department
oh and I was holding him he said what's
this it's scooby-doo's boner goes beyond
your standard sword and Sworcery tail
into some heavy surrealism you know I
think I know what he's referred to I
there was a Ralph Bakshi film called
Wizards is it because I get killed in
like two minutes I never saw it and then
it came up on my cable last week so I
watch it for the first time and I was
really impressed I said this is really
good
and ambitious I wish I had a bigger part
I said I love the whole thing until the
end credits were they spelled my name
wrong H am i L
closer to radio drama than Kitty fair
this is the strangest BG film of the
year it's probably the future version of
Batman
it was mask of the phantasm listen I
read that script and I thought I wish
the live-action films were this
well-written a lot of people think until
the Christopher Nolan versions that that
was the best Batman script that was ever
produced nice big when mammoth
dandelions pop out spores the site is as
seductive as it is lethal gee that might
be one of those foreign animated films
castle in the sky oh Nausicaa I love
doing those because the Japanese have a
sense of fantasy that's unlike always
our sensibilities so everything's
slightly weird this is not a film for
gentlemen it's for us the greatest
unwashed bloodthirsty audience
it's an immaculately engineered
laugh-out-loud appeal to our own
depravity
this is Kingsman oh my god it's
hilariously over the top and my
barometer is my wife Mary Lou and she
does just that scene in the church
because I said to her I said it's not
like real violence it's like Road Runner
wily coyote where he drops an anvil on
his head I mean it's so extreme that
it's silly I mean it's it's not played
for Gore and even my head exploded that
was remarkably immaculate
you're very good at this game
[Music]
[Music]